[Music]
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another edition of the ten oil
Chronicles
in this video I want to discuss
something that I noticed in one of the
newly released photos from Entertainment
Weekly Entertainment Weekly released
several new photos that were taken
during the filming a game of Thrones
Season seven and I did make a video
about those photos which you can find a
link for that video down in the
description but as I was looking over
these photos once again something caught
my attention that I've been thinking
about ever since so I figured I would
make a video about this and hopefully
together we can come to some sort of
conclusion this is a tinfoil chronicles
edition so I do have a few different
ideas but no guarantees any of this is
going to happen but let's try to have
some fun anyway I'm sure by now most of
you have seen this new photo of torment
standing inside a wonderful courtyard
but if you look a little bit closer you
can see that Brienne is standing right
there in the back but if you look even
closer than that you can see that this
person standing here in Brienne's armor
is not Brienne that is a grown-ass man
my friends that is Brienne stunt double
wearing her armor on standby waiting to
be filmed but the question is what are
they about to film Jon Snow and company
have already taken back Winterfell from
the Bolton's so why would Brienne need a
body double where she should be safely
inside of Winterfell walls this is
something that I've been thinking about
and I've been trying to decide what the
hell could possibly be taking place
right here if you look off to the left
you can see that there are other men
dressed in full armor leaving the
courtyard and if you look right behind
tormund you can see that there are
several different swords laying there on
the ground so we have men dressed from
head to toe and armor a few swords
laying there and Brienne stunt-double
standing in the back
plus we have tormund standing right here
looking all white Ivan it feels to me
like we could get some sort of action
sequence here perhaps some sort of fight
or duel at the very least Brienne is a
big and strong woman who I'm sure can
handle filming most scenes but for her
to need a body double makes me think
something much more physical was going
to be taking place perhaps within
winterfell's walls which has me very
intrigued considering she should be safe
there
unless someone shows up causing beef or
something happens between Brienne and
Littlefinger we already know from
previous seasons that brie and a little
finger are not friends and I think it's
safe to say that Brienne may even to spy
Littlefinger one of my favorite teams
from last season was in moles town when
Sean's and Littlefinger met privately to
have a little chat and at some point
during that conversation Shonda has
Littlefinger if he knew what rains he
did to her which left little finger
speechless for once
until Brienne grabbed the handle of her
sword and she said lady Songza asked you
a question I thought that was a great
moment
and it also let us know that Brienne
wasn't playing games with Littlefinger
which leads me to one of the other new
photos that Entertainment Weekly
released which is this one of Brienne
smiling but when you look a little bit
closer to this one which some of you did
point out in one of my last videos you
can see Littlefinger in the back and you
can also see Songz's hair right over
Brienne shoulder so at some point during
this scene between tones and
Littlefinger
we know that Brienne is going to go up
there and be involved with the scene -
and given the look on their faces this
might not be a pleasant conversation
that's taking place here we know what
Littlefinger ones from Sansa and based
off of Saunders reaction from this last
season we know that she isn't ready to
give it to him and I think if jon is
gone when this scene is taking place and
Littlefinger is back in songs as the
heir playing his games Brienne is going
to see right through his [ __ ]
and she's not going to allow a little
finger to control her if she can help it
with this body double being on the set I
think we can potentially see some sort
of fight happen between Brienne and
someone else maybe one of these Vale
soldiers usually when they are just
hanging out at the castle like this they
don't usually walk around with their
full armor on there would be no reason
to do that but let's take a closer look
at those soldiers leaving the courtyard
if you zoom in on them some more you can
see that they are wearing the same armor
in the same uniform that the other Vale
soldiers wear they had the same color
cloaks on with the steel shoulder covers
and their helmets come to a tip whatever
is taking place here is going to involve
Brian Gorman those Vale soldiers and
possibly Littlefinger and so on zone
Shaun's a little finger maybe having a
heated conversation up there which then
causes Brienne to go up there and
confront Littlefinger possibly even draw
her sword on Littlefinger which we know
she's willing to do we can see Brienne
is up here now was on to Littlefinger so
I do think she comes into play during
this scene between those two and I think
of Brienne controls Littlefinger
threatens Littlefinger in some sort of
way that may cause the Vale soldiers to
step in to protect him Brienne could end
up getting into a serious fight with
some of these men causing her to need
her body double to step in for her
if Brienne ends up getting into some
sort of fight with Littlefinger or these
men don't be surprised to see torment
step in to crack some skulls to protect
his life you can also tell by the
direction Littlefinger and Sons are
looking in that something is going to be
taking place down in that courtyard -
now I know this is all just speculation
and tinfoil based off a one photo of a
body double but just work with me here
and hear me out
let's go over another possible scenario
maybe nothing happens between
Littlefinger and Brienne perhaps she
gets into a fight with someone else that
would warrant a stunt double who else
would possibly have beef with the
Honorable Brienne of Tarth
we know the Hound is heading that way
and who's to say they don't bump heads
once again now I know the hounds a
different man by now but that doesn't
mean they won't ever fight again she is
still carrying that Lannister gold that
we know the Hound despises and the plot
league also said that when Arya Stark
shows back up at Winterfell her and
Brienne get into some sort of sparring
match and considering most of the plot
League seems to be right goes far
who's to say Arya doesn't show up and
have problems with her - from what I saw
in the season 7 trailer it appears that
almost the entire plot leaked is
accurate so I won't necessarily rule
this out just yet and we also got that
teaser about a month or two ago and all
it showed was someone holding Brienne
sword Oathkeeper now obviously that can
mean several different things or it
could mean nothing at all I think it
could also be foreshadowing something
about Brienne End or her sword I won't
be surprised if her sword ends up in
someone else's hands by the end her
carrying around that Lannister sword and
the North has caused her problems
already and I wouldn't doubt it if it
doesn't cause her some more problems in
the future
but comment below and tell me what you
think has taking place in the scene why
do you think Breanna would need a body
double while she's at Winterfell what
could she possibly be doing to need one
we don't see any other actors body
double standing around so it must be
something physical that involves her
considering the Vale soldiers are over
there dressed head-to-toe in steel in
Brienne body double was wearing her
armor it must have something to do with
and possibly even torment now am I just
crazy or am i looking too far into this
let me know down below thanks for
stopping by once again to check out the
video I appreciate your support and
feedback as always and a special thank
you to all the supporters of the channel
on patreon don't forget to leave me some
questions over there so I can do a Q&A
video for you thanks a lot now see you
down below bye